Bambi wake up we have
company now first of all I've never met
a child who actually likes this movie I
don't know anyone my age who liked Bambi
growing up Bambi is one of the weakest
films in the Disney
Cannon and yet it's viewed as a classic
does it happen to be released in the'
40s although it could have been released
last year based on the fact that the
villains in this movie are the hunters
who shot Bambi's mom but they were OB
viously entirely justified in doing so
first of all because venison is
delicious those Hunters I'm guessing
made some you know great venison steaks
maybe some deer jerky out of Bambi's mom
which is a fact that could have brought
Bambi some comfort and Solace if anyone
had explained it to him but they never
did